[Musique]
écrire et déclamer son poème laissons
les Muses nous guider la nature nous
inspirait et l'épreuve du pentathlon sur
les arts du château de Versailles nous
gagnerons ou encore imaginer une chanson
sur une mélodie du 17e siècle
environ 3000 collégiens des Yvelines et
des Hauts-de-Seine ont pu découvrir le
château de Versailles différemment grâce
à des ateliers pédagogiques c'est en
même temps culturel et en même temps
amusant moi j'aime bien parce qu'en fait
on fait plusieurs activités aussi donc
on peut pas on s'ennuie pas et on fait
on apprend des choses
[Musique]
musique art de la Seine concert cette
année pour les établissements scolaires
cette journée s'inscrit dans le projet
Pentathlon des arts cette année le
pentathlon des arts pouvait toucher
plusieurs professeurs du collège et
notamment l'atelier théâtre c'est
pourquoi nous avons choisi d'emmener ses
élèves là aujourd'hui participer à cette
journée découvrir un petit peu le
château sous un autre angle c'est pas la
première fois qu'on participe au projet
et tout simplement pour leur faire
découvrir déjà le parc du château le
château de Versailles je commence à
parsoit au final ils viennent pas
toujours mais malgré qu'il soit pas si
loin que ça cette initiative est portée
par les départements des Yvelines et des
Hauts-de-Seine en partenariat avec le
château de Versailles depuis 2019 pour
beaucoup c'était une première il n'était
jamais venu visiter la demeure de Louis
XIV
[Musique]